surfing in pororoca is very dangerous
any mistake can cost your life
but it's such a good feeling that when
we're on the wave we forget everything
[Music]
my name is sérgio laus I'm a
professional surfer specialist in the
pororoca phenomenon with two surfing world records
the longest wave in the world in the
amazon pororoca is the name given to
the china tide phenomenon in brazil sun
millions of cubic meters of water that
has been advancing from the ocean into the
river covering unimaginable distances
we can surf and the longest waves in
the world  world
the pororoca wave is totally
different from the ocean in the ocean we
are surfing in the sea salt water
so we float more
already in the river we have denser fresh water
so we cannot have
much fluctuation fashion in pororoca it
can  vary a lot from its
size we can have waves of half a meter or
waves up to four meters in phase
the waves are very strong and it comes with
a flood of water at  we have many
trunks paulo gambus in the middle of the way
surfing in pororoca is something supreme where
we can try to have a very
intimate contact with nature because we
are in the biggest biome on the planet and surfing a
fashion that has practically no end
is indescribable
[Music]